pessoal 6 de agosto de 2015
vocês lembram que o estado você estava
fazendo e eu me lembro era uma manhã
cinza chuvosa nublada aquelas que quando
abre o olho na cama de ouvir aqueles que
as gotas aquele aguaceiro ainda na rua
do pensa
cara eu vou ficar mais tempo aqui e eu
não quero trabalhar só que nesse dia
especificamente foi isso que acabou
acontecendo comigo essa vontade tão
intensa de não trabalhar e ficar mais
tempo na cama mais tempo pensando
refletindo por que será que eu tô indo
trabalhar hoje e será que eu tenho feito
tem entregado algum tipo de valor para o
mundo já que alguém tenha se importado
com as entregas que tenho feito e isso
foi me incomodando de casa até o trajeto
trabalho
chegando lá eu abri o computador vejo
minhas tarefas respondem alguns e-mails
e entre estes e mails
eu abro em branco e mandando um e meio
mortal diretamente pra minha chefe
queria chefe hashtag partiu literalmente
tá então mandei um e mail pedindo as
contas minha esposa não sabia a não
saber
mandei meio da noite e tchau pra minha
chefe manda um email pra galera geral da
empresa é uma empresa grande golo de
moda
peguei minhas coisas e voltei pra casa
chego em casa pulo no sofá feliz da vida
com a chuvarada caindo né
ligo a tv eo netflix só que não consegui
assistir nada que une a outra pergunta
que veio à cabeça foi putz
e agora agora pedir as contas
a pedir as contas já a não sei viver
como gigolô ou com alguma coisa parecida
assim a esposa trabalhando estava em
caso de cueca no sofá em uma manhã de
quarta feira tá isso começou a matar na
minha cabeça o que tinha motivado
energizado a tomar essa decisão de uma
forma tão drástica numa manhã uma quarta
feira sendo que já tinha uma carreira
consolidada uma empresa consolidada e
tinha um ambiente estável de trabalho
academia militar norte americana tem um
termo muito interessante para tratar
alguns cenários fora do normal quando
ela se encontra em contexto de guerra
o termo utilizado é vulgar
é um acrônimo está no qual ele
contestaria um cenário que muda de
estado de forma muito repentina tá essa
mudança de estádio tá é justamente um
contexto volátil no qual os soldados no
campo de batalha se encontram e essa
volatilidade essa mudança de estado
acaba acontecendo pra ambiente cenários
incertos
ou seja não acaba acontecendo o cenário
psc-df planejados pela pelo então as
altas patentes do exército são cenários
realmente novos insetos que acabam
deixando a esse componente estratégico
no campo de batalha extremamente
complexo
você tem mudança de estado tá a
incerteza que misturadas
só que aí a gente tem o ponto específico
desse cenário huck é justamente que
estando no ambiente volátil incerto e
complexo ele pode ser muito bom ou muito
ruim
isso vai depender de quem vai depender
de quem estiver realmente com a bota
suja de barro lá no campo de batalha e
tomar as melhores decisões com as
informações com os dados com o contexto
no qual eles estão vivendo ali naquele
momento todas as grandes estratégias
desenhadas pelas pelos generais daquele
pessoal de alta patente que ficou numa
sala confortável com ar condicionado tá
esperando a tropa voltar já não faz mais
sentido precisa se que aqueles realmente
aqueles soldados aqueles que estão na
frente liderando com aquela situação
sejam menos operários ou seja sigam
menos processos e sejam mais
inteligentes para tomar melhores
decisões com as informações que eles têm
naquele momento e esse termo pessoa
vulca que o termo que nasceu na academia
militar acabou sendo aplicado hoje em
nosso contexto de um mundo nosso
contexto de negócios justamente porque
devido ao boom da abundância de soluções
e serviços têm opções que nós temos no
nosso dia a dia
muitos deles proporcionados pela
tecnologia e pela nossa capacidade de
gerar coisas novas a partir da nossa
criatividade do empreendedorismo
apercebeu se que esse cenário tem
produzido não somente novos negócios mas
também novas pessoas basicamente uma
nova geração uma nova uma nova geração
orientada muito mais essas tomadas de
decisões um pouco mais imediatista swan
que são em média imediatista orientadas
justamente na entrega e na captura de
valor nesse processo percebe se que quem
começou a entrar no universo
à tarde a partir do ano passado 2.018
este ano 2009 provavelmente nasceu
depois de 2000 depois de 2000 eu tive
esse choque porque eu acabei me tornando
o professor universitário também ano
passado com meus os novatos aos novos
entrantes a gente faz aquela tarde nome
inicial para perguntar quem é e não de
veículos anos tem a grande maioria
nasceu depois de 2000 em 2000 entrega da
unidade aqui eu estava no segundo ano do
colegial
essa turma pessoa quando este ano ali
seus seis anos de idade
viram no facebook lançado quando este 17
lá em 2007 havia um iphone foi lançado
quando existiam 10 chegou o instagram e
hoje eles estão aí na universidade estão
batendo também um ambiente de trabalho
para começar a desenvolver essas novas
soluções novas trajetórias profissionais
deles
e nesse contexto nós estamos também
imerso nesse ambiente está no qual a
resistência habituado com novas práticas
e novos exercícios profissionais que não
estão mais alinhadas ao modelo mais
industrial ortodoxo no qual a gente
acaba respeitando muito mais uma posição
do que respectivamente uma entrega de
valor dentro da organização e esse
contexto vulca tem provocado justamente
uma grande busca por um sujeito desses
indivíduos que estão dentro desse mundo
novo um ambiente mais restrito no qual a
gente tem essa visão de pouca abundância
de ofertas como foi a nossa era
industrial está no começo do século 20
era bem comum que a gente fosse pago
para fazer algo que a gente era bom
também tinha o primeiro ambiente uma
profissão e era isso que eu sentia
naquela manhã naquela quarta-feira de
agosto
eu percebi que eu estava realmente
cumpre um papel cumprido uma profissão
eu era bom em algo e era pago pra isso o
que me incomodava naquela manhã era
justamente que que por aquilo que eu era
pago talvez não seria algo que o mundo
precisará se eu estava vendo o propósito
é que eu estava vendo uma realmente algo
que me tirasse da cama para que
entregasse valor pro mundo e faltava
realmente uma vocação então essa foi a
minha primeira grande provocação desta
manhã
será que eu tenho feito tem feito
sentido pelo mundo isso que eu tenho
feito que o mundo precisa de mim
realmente é aquilo que eu gosto de fazer
aqui em chicago no segundo ano
e é justamente a nossa missão pra que eu
estou fazendo isso daqui e no fim
obviamente se eu fazer aquilo que eu ama
que eu amo e ser pago com isso realmente
não terá o que me desperte paixão
então eu percebi naquela manhã era
justamente o que eu tinha uma profissão
mas ainda me faltava vocação me faltava
realmente uma missão de vida e ao que me
despertasse paixão pra que eu realmente
enfrentar aquela chuva naquela quarta
feira fria de agosto
e nessa minha busca por ãos durante a
minha trajetória nos últimos anos
acabei desenvolvido outras práticas de
carreira acabei ajudando outras
profissões os profissionais outras
organizações através do desenvolvimento
criativo nos seus potenciais internos e
externos e dentro dessas dessa
experiência eu acabei tirando quatro
grandes lições são aprendizados que eu
tenho levado pra mim como profissional
como pessoa e também para as
organizações no qual eu tenho passado
dentre esses quatro aprendizados eu
destaco o primeiro ataque a nossa que é
justamente a nossa capacidade de não ter
uma fixação por mapas por trajetórias
prontas por planos perfeitos e ter mais
orientações ampcon a comentar a bússola
ou seja a gente tem muito mais
orientações de onde seguir como seguir
para conseguir do que respectivamente
uma ordem exata de que passos tomar a
serem tomados e que ponto b que destino
final nós teremos nem toda essa nossa
trajetória profissional e pessoal e
nessa nessa discussão sobre ter mas não
ter mapas e bússolas fica muito claro
que dentro desse mundo ágil no qual a
gente se encontra hoje as coisas mudam
muito rápido e aquele plano b que você
planejou hoje pode não estar naquele
ponto que tu mensurou amanhã tá muito
pior daqui um mês ou daqui a um ano não
faz muito mais sentido você em vez de
gravar pins a cravar pontos específicos
no futuro a médio longo prazo o ct
orientações de como você vai tomar essas
duas suas decisões no decorrer da
trajetória que você vai caminhando que
com as oportunidades vão surgindo nosso
dia a dia fica muito mais fácil a gente
realmente era muito mais valor delas do
que respectivamente está realmente
olhando para algo muito bitolado algo
muito fechado então ter bússola em vez
de mapas acabam gerando muito mais
oportunidades e desenvolvimento do que
respectivamente está seguindo o mapa e
muitas vezes em um mapa desenhado por
outros no qual a gente vai conseguindo
sonhos de
cheiros a segunda grande lição que o
time sair é que merda acontece shift
raps tá e isso pessoal é muito bom há no
momento que a gente se permite com que
os erros aconteçam existe um fenômeno
chamado falha produtiva a nossa
capacidade de desenvolvimento e
crescimento ela carrega s absurdamente é
muito mais fácil você se desenvolver
tirando 17 o que você tirando a quem
você tira um 10
quem tirou dez provavelmente decorou
muito o passo a passo para seguir nesse
mapa e quem tira 17 vai acabar e nas
orientações para que ele faça as coisas
certas na próxima oportunidade que ele
estiver com essa nossa capacidade de
permitir com que a falha produtiva
aconteça no nosso dia-a-dia da
oportunizando com que a gente se
desenvolva e cresça a partir desses
percalços no que encontra durante os
desafios é muito mais interessante do
que muitas vezes começado sem esse plano
perfeito que nos bloqueia que nos a ser
ceia de riscos que a vida nos
proporciona todos os dias da nossa
capacidade de fazer com que a exploração
a gente realmente avance começa a
caminhar por novos caminhos do que
respectivamente exportação que a gente
analisar de forma muito frio e detalhado
o que já aconteceu no passado acabamos
permitindo errar mais e aprender mais
com esses erros o desafio é justamente
que errar rápido e barato do que errar
por muito tempo de uma forma cara
a terceira grande lição que tirei essa
experiência de vida de dos últimos anos
empreendendo dentro de organizações e
com diversos profissionais foi
justamente de nós temos uma proposta de
valor muito clara a nossa capacidade de
justamente que entender que nós somos tá
o que nós conhecemos e que nós
conhecemos ea partir daí a gente começa
a desenvolver o que realmente estou
oferecendo para o mundo
essa nossa capacidade de olhar para nós
como se a gente fosse um do próprio
negócio em si como se nós fôssemos
também o produto e quem sabe esse
negócio produto realmente ele entrega
valor para a sociedade para o mundo de
alguma forma qual é o meu benefício
chave no qual realmente as pessoas vão
conseguir usufruir valor
qual é o meu papel dentro da sociedade
qual é o papel da minha comunidade do
papel dentro dessa organização
qual é a minha proposta de valor e isso
pessoal e só consegue fazendo muita
experimentação no uso ofertando erros e
acertos como nós vimos na edição
anterior
assim a gente vai refinando a nossa
proposta de valor sabendo que proposta
de valor é algo que muda constantemente
o que a gente percebe que o valor hoje
pode não ser percebido como valor amanhã
talvez muito menos daqui um ano ou daqui
cinco anos
é algo constante mudança em constante
evolução e só depende de nós e de
aprendizado contínuo e quanto mais
experimentarmos maiores são as chances
de a gente conseguir realmente
desenvolver e proporcionar valor dentro
das nossas tarefas e nas nossas
atividades
a quarta grande lição que eu tiro dessa
minha experiência foi justamente de ter
uma visão muito mais e desenvolvimento
de portfólio do que respectivamente uma
visão de desenvolvimento de currículo
isso é que a gente leva para a vida
também em vez de você ficar colecionando
selos empresas x y z
a marca xyz durante a sua carreira
coleciona muito mais feitos
sabendo se que um perfeito é a coleção
de vários feitos conglomerados ali
dentro da nossa capacidade de em vez de
ficar correndo atrás de pequenas
bandeiras acabam deixando algum tipo de
valor da nossa história justamente a
gente começar a entregar mais valor para
o mundo através de diversas realizações
o que eu tenho feito o que eu consigo
acordar com um case para que eu consiga
compilar dentro de um portfólio de
realizações seja um designer seja um
computador seja um advogado pode valer
muito mais a pena neste nosso mundo
julga você contar como você tem gerado
um valor para o mundo através de causos
tá e 15 específicos do que
respectivamente dizer que passou por
ponto abc de iof
e aqui pessoal tem um exercício muito
forte reflexão sobre a nossa formação
que muitas vezes é formado desenvolvido
durante a nossa educação para justamente
construir um bom currículo a ser um
produto numa bandeja numa prateleira a
ser puxado a qualquer momento não seria
mais interessante talvez em vez de a
gente ser um produto na prateleira em
ser justamente que ofertador de serviços
que têm benefícios chaves faça sentido
para o mundo então colecionar esses
cases para que nosso dia a dia começa a
entregar mais valor pro mundo e
interessante ea diferença do currículo e
portfólio é que muitas vezes o currículo
e acaba tendo valor muitas vezes de
ponto direto né
ou seja para quem está recebendo para
que nós estamos enviando dificilmente
vocês vão ver currículos compartilhados
dificilmente é muito mais fácil a gente
ver causos histórias que eles
compartilhados que tem o participante e
personagens entre essas histórias
então ele tem um potencial de escala e
de construção de comunidades muito forte
então a nossa capacidade de escala de
com de conexão com a comunidade a partir
das nossas histórias
será que por meio de um currículo ou por
meio de um portfólio pela minha
experiência por ter feito muito mais
sentido neste nosso mundo boca e dentro
dessa provocação dessas quatro lições
o que se percebeu ou seja somente que
não existem mais padrões pré
estabelecidos em lei as receitas prontas
no qual nos quais a gente consiga
realmente se basear em se estruturar
está a aberta é um termo que vem da área
de informática que digitalmente diz
justamente que aquele produto que está
ainda na sua fase experimental na sua
fase de testes e fala que o mundo está
buscando aquele cenário os militares
apontaram extremamente complexo e
incerto e que traz um ar de volatilidade
e e e ambigüidade permite com que nós
sejamos extremamente experimentais e
beta tá nada está pronto tudo está em
constante evolução e provavelmente a sua
versão de hoje a sua versão experimental
e o futuro amanhã o seu ar de amanhã
daqui um ano e assim prosseguir e assim
por diante e foi isso que eu descobri
naquela manhã quando fiz aquela pergunta
e agora é justamente ficar agora eu
preciso realmente experimentar já fazem
5 45 anos que eu tenho nesse processo
experimental muita coisa acontecendo
provavelmente o igor está aqui hoje não
tem nada a ver comigo que estará amanhã
o ano que vem entregando valor para o
mundo então eu continuo sendo assim a
versão beta é uma versão experimental
fazendo ainda toda a manhã
aquela pergunta chave que me provocou
naquela quarta-feira por que raios
outros 100 da cama de manhã
será que alguém deveria se importar com
isso muito obrigado
[Aplausos]